la moción de censura contra el gobierno
de elizabeth bound no prosperó 146 votos
a favor nada más de los 289 que se
necesitaban para que fuera aprobada esta
moción fue presentada por las nubes la
coalición de izquierda y fue matilde
para no la jefe de los insumisos en la
asamblea nacional la que hizo la
presentación de este texto con palabras
muy duras contra elizabeth ban contra la
primera ministra a quien tildó de
anomalía democrática diciendo que su
legitimidad pues estaba en la era de
cuestionarse debido a los resultados de
las legislativas por un lado y por otro
el hecho de que ella no hubiera pedido
el voto de confianza de la asamblea
nacional la semana pasada cuando realizó
su discurso de política general luego a
esto bona dijo que esto más que todo era
una moción de postura y que se podría
utilizar el tiempo mejor sobre todo
tratando asuntos que le importan a los
franceses reunieron cerca de dos horas y
media de debate sobre todo como un
ajuste de cuentas entre la izquierda y
la derecha todo esto sabiendo es que
tanto la reagrupación nacional la
extrema derecha como los conservadores
de los republicanos no votaron a favor
de esta moción de censura
dijeron además que no querían impedir el
actuar del gobierno pero que no por esto
significaba que tenían la confianza en
todo caso que no le estaban otorgando la
confianza ni a bona ni tampoco a emanuel
a maco el resultado de esta votación era
algo que ya se esperaba pero era la
oportunidad en todo caso para la cniv de
demostrar que son la principal fuerza de
oposición